hi guys welcome to our muzzle flash
tutorial now what is the good muzzle
flash tutorial with no muzzle flashes if
you're not I provided free muzzle flash
and smoke puffs at the end of this video
for your use instructions for how to
extract those elements are in the box
below or you can click on the annotation
that pops up the steps I'm going to show
here are an After Effects but you can do
these steps in most editing programs as
well I like to create a composition by
dragging my footage down to the create
composition button it creates a
composition with the same dimensions and
length as the footage that you're gonna
be working with the first step is to
place your muzzle flash correctly it
should be only one frame long so that's
replacing it you can trim it with the
shortcuts alt or option bracket left and
alt or option bracket right now muzzle
flash should be pretty big a good point
of reference is the size of the gun a
pistol muzzle flash should be about the
same size as a pistol and a rifle flash
it's just a touch smaller than a rifle
if you don't like the colors of the
muzzle flash or don't think it's
matching your scene you can actually use
the filter Colorama basically it gives
you a gradient here in a circle that
corresponds to the bright points of the
muzzle flash so as you go around the
circle that goes from Bright to dark and
you can change the colors and we map
them however you'd like pretty powerful
also if your muzzle flash is too crisp
around the edges you can apply a radial
blur switch it over to zoom mode make
sure it's centered correctly and then
just adjust it to wherever you need to
be in this case the muzzle flash we're
using has soft edges so we don't need it
here anyways once we have the flash
positioned next step is to give it a bit
of a hazy glow first I duplicate the
layer with ctrl D or command D if you're
on a Mac and then apply a Gaussian blur
and then you just simply turn up the
blur until you get a nice haziness that
kind of sits around the flash as you can
see here you'll have to kind of play by
eye here if you're in a bright scene
you're in need less glow if you're in a
dark scene you're going to need more
glow you're essentially trying to
replicate the effect of the light of the
muzzle flash coming through the lens of
the camera and kind of creating the hazy
glow or bloom next you want to adjust
the transparency of the glow
sometimes you want a more subtle
sometimes you want a more obvious it's
up to you after you have a decent
looking muzzle flash you'll want to add
a smoke puff smoke puff is what makes
all the difference and makes it look
real take your smoke puff and position
it over the flash
you'll want to cut off the first frame
usually because a smoke puffs are
already kind of the expanded after the
muzzle flash also set it to screen mode
and then you'll have the correct
transparency with them smoke in this
case I'm holding shift when I rescale to
keep the proportions correct also
hitting W on your keyboard gives you the
rotation tool so I can then spin it and
kind of make it you know go in the
direction I want to and then hitting B
on the keyboard brings you back to my
pointer so I can move it back into place
the smoke puffs should be bigger than
the muzzle flash not by much but
definitely bigger also once again adjust
the transparency to a spot where you
kind of like it where it's subtle now
one thing to keep in mind is different
types of guns without different amounts
of smoke also if you have a gun that's
doing rapid fire and a lot of muscle
flashes you're going to want to keep the
transparency really low per smoke puffs
otherwise you can have just a white haze
covering up your entire scene now you'll
probably notice that with this moving
camera the smoke puff looks kind of
weird so just sitting in one spot while
the elbow footage moves behind it in
this case we're going to get a little
bit advanced and do some motion tracking
it's like the footage layer and hit the
track motion button and then I position
the tracker over a point of contrast in
the scene in this case a little dot
that's on the end of this board so
anyways I hit play to track forward and
there you have it so now the next step
is to go create a null layer basically
what this allows me to do is I will
apply the track motion to the null layer
first by hitting edit target here
selecting the null then hitting OK and
then my window was a little short here
but then I go to apply generally you
want your plate your playhead to be at
the first frame we're going to be
applying keyframes anyways now that mil
has been given the motion from the
motion tracker now anything I want to be
motion tracking the scene I simply just
parent it to the null in this case I
parent the smoker to the null and now
the smoke moves with the scene and it
looks like it's part of the scene so
there you have it that's uh that's
pretty close right there now if you want
to get a little extra complicated we can
add a little bit of light on the guy
from the muzzle flash this is kind of
this kind of be the icing on the cake
you don't always have to do this but it
makes things look really nice my
favorite way to do this is create a
duplicate layer of the footage set the
in and out points so it's only two
frames long where the muzzle flash is
mask it off
where I want the glow to be applied and
I'm going to set it to add mode and
that's going to actually brighten the
layer in a certain way that kind of like
now I hit F and that brings the mask
feathering turn up tell everything's
nice and soft and then I can adjust the
brightness just by adjusting the
transparency of the second layer now the
next step to is that the muzzle flash is
usually kind of like a yellow or orange
color so I'm just going to apply a
hue/saturation filter check the colorize
box and then adjust the the hue and the
saturation to make that that duplicated
layer kind of like a orangish yellowish
red and this kind of depends on what
color muzzle flash you're using and
other things like that but this is just
an easy way to tint that extra
brightness layer a little bit anyways
the final step is to animate the
transparency so I'm starting at around
like 50% transparency from the muzzle
flash is there and then I go forward two
frames and drop the transparency to zero
so you kind of have a nice like to frame
brightness like popping in and then
dimming over the course of two friends
and that's it that's all you need to
know from making the muzzle flash have
fun good luck making action movies don't
get in trouble
bless you Sam